we're in the occupied West Bank town of
Hebron right now we're clashes have just
broken out between Palestinian
protesters and Israeli soldiers heparin
is the epicenter of the tensions right
now and it one of the reasons is because
this area which is inhabited
predominantly by Palestinians is
surrounded by illegal Israeli
settlements and that creates a lot of
friction will tell you more this is
something normal that you see in the
city here it's because in the city in
the centre of the city here there there
are illegal Israelis according to the
international law
Israeli settlements are in the heart of
the city right there right there behind
the shipment that's why people are like
what you can see now is that there are
people throwing stones and then what did
I find the occupation forces the tear
gas you're guessing the sound bombs
right is that what's happening this is
do you guys the sound bombs so we're
approaching your house right now by the
checkpoint you're acting like this is
totally normal
I'm kind of scared right now it's
because I lived my whole life you know
saying this seeing you know stun
grenades or tear gases the shooting here
shooting all of our data be careful
Bashar then I'm trying it up so bad
Michele Dana I don't want to go any
further cause it's kind of scary and it
looks like we're not gonna cross so tell
me how you would normally go
so how normal I go there there's a
checkpoint here it's called chick 156
and the only reason for it I see is to
push the people out of their homes and
their houses the reason why this Raquin
there is to humiliate people it's for
example when I pass the checkpoint I
need to take off my belt I need to take
of my my phone for example the day
before yesterday they forced me to take
off my shoes because my shoe my shoes
were beeped you know passing it because
there's metal
and it beeped this is normal I just saw
a huge thing fired and it's super loud
and he's like doesn't flinch it's it's
you know I ruin it can be scary it can
be like dangerous but this is how it is
there is a solution and the first real
solution in my opinion is to end this
illegal occupation it is depriving me
from my very very basic right you know
as a human being I have the right to
walk I can't walk to my house because
there is a checkpoint that cuts the way
in front of me to go to my house I don't
have the right of dignity you know every
time I pass this checkpoint you know
sometimes they force me to take off my
pants there's no dignity so that the
solution is ending the occupation and in
the circulation
you